fundamentalmente lo que busca es una
reestructura del instituto con el
argumento de acuerdo con los autores de
la iniciativa El presidente y sus
partidos de generar ahorros de evitar
que se derroche el dinero de una
política de austeridad sin embargo lo
que Argumenta la autoridad electoral
actual es que uno de los aspectos más
preocupantes es que en esta reestructura
desaparece las trescientas juntas
distritales cada cada junta estaba
integrada por cinco vocales que pues se
dedicaban a organizar el proceso
electoral No nada más en en época de
elecciones sino durante permanentemente
es decir dónde se van a ubicar las
casillas el listado nominal y ahora con
la Reforma en lugar de estos cinco
vocales habrá un solo vocal operativo en
estos que serán ahora órganos auxiliares
esto a juicio de el presidente del INE
es dinamitar al instituto es destazar al
INE y poner en riesgo la certeza de lo
que Hasta ahora ha hecho de manera
integral el Instituto bueno y lo
estábamos adelantando porque el que
fuera hasta hoy el secretario ejecutivo
del INE radicó demandas contra la
reforma al considerar la
inconstitucional Cuáles son las razones
detrás de esta y otras querellas contra
la iniciativa gubernamental
Así es el propio Edmundo Jacobo
interpuso un amparo en juzgados
federales y un juicio de protección de
los Derechos políticos del ciudadano
ante el tribunal electoral por
considerar que se están violando sus
garantías constitucionales pero no solo
eso también el propio instituto
interpuso un juicio electoral ante el
tribunal electoral del poder judicial
por considerar que se invaden las
facultades las competencias del propio
instituto por qué Porque el llamado Plan
B ordena el cese inmediato de este
funcionario pero la Constitución indica
que es el consejo general del instituto
el que debe nombrar a esta persona
a la par de ello también se argumenta
que ninguna ley puede tener una acción
privativa es decir no puede ir dirigida
a una persona en específico de modo tal
que ya están estos recursos y otros más
por ejemplo diputados del partido
revolucionario institucional han
comenzado ya la recolección de firmas
para interponer una acción de
inconstitucionalidad ante la suprema
corte se requieren 167 firmas y el
objetivo es agotar todas las instancias
jurídicas para revertir estas reformas
que la oposición y el propio órgano
electoral consideran regresivas y
autoritarias